so Robocop's coming back and there's a
creepy pedophile looking man once said
I'd buy that for a dollar when I was a
kid I was like don't do not accept candy
from that guy so a remake of robocop
coming out and calling it a remake is
opening the floodgates of commenters
being like it's a Robocop movie that's
not related to the last Robocop movie
they're totally redoing Robocop movies
thus it is a remake we have a trailer
for it the trailer I'm not gonna lie
it's kind of a mixed bag for me there's
a lot in this trailer where I'm like
that looks cool I'm undeniably looking
forward to this and other parts where
I'm like I wish they had done that a
little differently Murphy's a cop he's a
good cop and then he gets wasted by a
car bomb this time that's actually one
of the things I don't like he remember
the last Robocop there were a few thugs
and they were just wasting Murphy they
slowly start blowing his limbs off it
was really humbling it sucked ass looks
like Caviezel and passion of the christ'
just getting his ass kicked or like dude
leave Murphy alone then these guys just
go all out just balls deep waste the
[ __ ] out of him just shoot him up Murphy
drops to the ground you're like the
Murphy's dead they bring him back as the
cyborg Robocop this one he goes into his
cars like it's a lot less personal for
me it's a lot less gritty and disturbing
and again it's a trailer it's too early
to tell but I'm just saying as I see it
now I can't see a car bomb being
grittier and just more disturbing than a
few thugs wasting this good cop
maybe it'll prove me wrong in the movie
point is he comes back as Robocop when I
first saw a picture a Robocop I was like
oh alright well I guess he's all black
now no he looks good because it has the
classic Robocop colors you know he's got
the silver on black his visor does that
goon thing and that's that's really cool
they started getting excited about it
and then Beetlejuice is like making more
practical make I'm look let's go with
black
the suit is just so monochromatic it's
not as interesting yeah I like the way
the red visor looks on the blackness as
the Cylon thing going on that looks
awesome you remember the first Iron Man
when Tony Stark was making the Iron Man
suit he was like you know what throw a
little hotrod red in there and now you
have a couple different colors the
colors accent themselves and they
complement each other and it looks
really cool this one you had that you
had a couple different colors you knew
you had the silver on black and it
looked cool they're like yeah you know
what make it less interesting do like
Tony Stark was going to do before he got
smart and added another color but then
you look at the trailer and there are
quite a few scenes where he's wearing
this silver Robocop suit on black it
looks like classic Robocop so I'm
wondering does he have the classic
Robocop colors and then he gets the
black near the very end or does he have
the classic Robocop colors and then gets
the black and then when he goes against
the company he gets his classic Robocop
colors back and there's the thing about
trailers it's too early to tell right
now but I'm just saying as I stand I
don't like the black suit as much as I
love the classic Robocop suit that he
actually does wear and I like the fact
that it shows his family dynamic he's
dealing with his family his kids like
you're a cyborg dad you need to speak to
who got blown up by a car bomb and
burned on so much of his body except his
right hand in his face your face is fine
that's important for a movie it's like
they were like don't touch his face we
need him to look good that would also be
a really cool thing what if like from
here up his face was all messed up you
know maybe he's missing an eye if he had
like a red eye implant maybe if his
visor goes up he looks like Hugh Borg
Locutus tromping around out there bad
things in the movie that's really cool
nothing's like dude dude you have 30
seconds to drop your weapon that thing's
gonna be right there I was like all
right this trailer got a lot cooler
nothing's going to be that cool though
it's not like it's gonna cap off with
something really awesome
come with me Oh God I'm just saying what
he said that I was like bad so classic
elbow grab all right that's really cool
again a couple of gripes about the suit
and how he got killed all and although
the movie does look cool I'm looking
forward to it I think it'll be a cool
sci-fi movie it's not like it's the
thing I'm waiting for though it's not
like I'm like between me and Robocop
lies the Hobbit we got to power through
the Hobbit and then I could finally get
to Robocop the trailer does look like a
cool movie I mean it's a good cop who
gets killed who gets turned into a
cyborg cop who's gonna try to be
controlled by this company but he has a
duality to him which the trailer does
show how he has programming in his head
but the human part of his brain is like
no I have freewill
so there's a conflict there I think
that's really cool so the new Robocop
movie have you seen the trailer and what
did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more cuz Dead or Alive
you're coming with me